- Your costar, Mandy Moore,
she's about to have her first baby.
Have you given her any parenting advice?
- You know, I haven't yet,
but, it's unbelievable.
This woman is like, she's radiant.
You would never know she was pregnant.
I mean, she's like, she looks
like she could run a marathon.
But I would tell her, if I did
have to tell her something,
I would say, "Get your
sleep now, lovely woman,"
"because when the babies come,
you're not gonna sleep much."
"And if you do sleep,
"it won't be the same quality of sleep."
Wouldn't you agree?
- Oh my God.
I literally, like on
Christmas vacation, my son,
I woke up in the middle
of the night and he's four
and I woke up and I was like (breathes in)
and I couldn't breathe, and
I was like, what's happening?
And they were having a
sleepover, my two little kids,
and he was sleeping on my body.
I was like, I mean, I already can't turn.
I don't turn if we have sleepovers,
'cause I have to keep my wide stance,
so they don't take over my spot.
He was full on, on top of me.
And I was like, "Bro, get
off, I can't breathe!"
- [Justin] Oh, they don't
care, they don't care.
- It is the worst sleep.